herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ist jetzt zusammen mit luca die habs
vielleicht schon am titel gesehen wir
bestellen heute mal wieder per zufall
essen ist natürlich ein bitterer da hast
du vielleicht stellen wir vielleicht
aber nur wenn der zufall mitspielt ich
würde sagen wir gehen erst mal die
lieferheld es gibt 64 kategorien das
heißt wir entscheiden zuerst welche
kategorie fragen basieren auf 164
l-serie wie viel grad sind es gerade
draußen sagen wir eine zahl zwischen 1
und 64 62 deshalb wehgetan
das muss ja jetzt erst mal nicht zeichen
weil das haben wir auch restaurants
vegetarisch dastehen wenn sie unter
anderem vegetarische gerichte und es ist
ja prinzipiell erst mal nichts falsch am
vegetarischem essen also vegetarisch die
kategorie steht schon mal pizza ist
obwohl hitze kälte und vegetarisch
irgendwie 10 jetzt wie viele restaurants
ist hier gibt es sind pro seite wie
viele 18 restaurants und nur so salat
leben da gibt es aber auch kein es gibt
auch sushi um ich hoffe so schickt man
kann so blieb's kraftakt du sagen eine
zahl zwischen 1 und 8
ja eine zahl zwischen 1 und 8 sind sag
mal eine zahl zwischen 1 und 7 40 nicht
sagen eine zeit zwischen 1 und 8 10
hier ja die cooking christliche kirche
ja locker und noch mal geil wie in
dessen ich hätte nicht mehr aber so
richtig gefreut aber du brauchst dich ja
nicht ähnlich ist für mich okay aber
nicht sogar wie sushi aber erstmal wie
sagen wir beide einigermaßen happy also
bisher hatten wir glück der lahn hat vor
allem und bewertungen der wirklich da
der oder wieder bewertungen wir gucken
mal wichtige stellen ich würde sagen
jeder zwei produkte die kategorien
beliebte gerichte lasse ich wieder aus
123 13 kategorien tag mehr eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 13 series kategorie 6 sek
garnelen war garnelen einem indischen
restaurant das klingt auch wirklich
alles ein bisschen crazy aber es ist
nicht gerade billig also vielleicht ist
es gutes essen
ja ja das stimmt schon ich würde sagen
jeder geld ich würde sagen jeder ich
will sagen jeder das den special ich
würde sagen jeder lässt in zypern
entscheidend gewandelt politiker ist
einfach nur mein video halte ich würde
sagen jeder von uns bestimmt sein
eigenes essen her zufall also ich habe
jetzt kanälen erwischt ich gucke welches
kanälen gerichtet sein wird sagen wir
eine zahl zwischen 1 und 10 5 okay so
machen 12345 mit frischem gemüse ingwer
knoblauch und spezial currysauce curry
mit garnelen knoblauch ingwer dem start
der also mein hauptgericht steht 13
kategorien gabst du das gerne nach
meiner fragen sagt man eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 13
ich bin mit 13 gold das war das letzte
nein zu 13 bestimmt so bisher das letzte
war getränke 13 alkoholische getränke
wir haben bereits 10 uhr
hier muss ich jetzt oder den bus
bestellt profitiert kein rotwein für
acht euro es wird ein zwei drei vier
fünf verschiedene bitte kein rot weil
die ersten drei sind die hre und die
letzten beiden sind weiß und rotwein
sagen eine zahl zwischen 1 und 5
indisches wie ihr indisches bl das ist
interessant kingfisher als das ist ein
reiner das ist mein fach schwach bist du
darfst noch eine haupt basieren ich kann
mir auch noch schnell mit trinken würde
ich sagen
am 1 und 2 also alkoholfreie und
alkoholische einst so geil oder ein
alkoholfreies getränk trinken sagt mir
eine zahl zwischen 1 und 20 03 das ist
für mich eine leckere cola light ich mag
kann im wald oder seid ihr könnt auch
ständig im cola light und wir waren
beide über die alle probieren bei ok
dann generiert dennoch ein hauptgericht
ich drücke die daumen dass es nichts mit
garnelen und knoblauch ist sagt nur eine
zahl zwischen 13 10 4 oder vorspeisen
salaten schicken boutiquen
also ich hätte mir so einen bart
schicken oder so besteht ja einfach nur
eine stelle tatsächlich auch mal also
wir haben 123 14 verschiedene schicken
speisen sagt nur eine zahl zwischen 1
und 14
wir haben die fünf und es ist das 12 345
abschicken mit paprika grünen erbsen
zwiebelsoße und kokosmilch okay ich
hätte viel mehr wert auf ihr gehabt
schicken man womit er einnahmen bild wir
haben beide eine hauptspeise und
getränke ich weiß genug also dachten
der ganze wald sprecher doch 31 eur 50
ich kenne jetzt auf bestellen dann sehen
wir uns gleich wieder so leute es ist
soweit ihr glaubt nicht wie viel zeit
vergangen ist es ist wirklich dunkel
geworden in der zwischenzeit vor zwei
stunden hab ich das essen bestellt die
erste liefert 33 minuten und ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass das noch eins
ist eigentlich aber ich will meinen
zwischendurch haben noch angerufen man
diese schon längst raus und noch eine
dreiviertelstunde gedauert so also die
haben uns verarscht auf jeden fall
ich hoffe dass ich lieber wenn du hier
wird haben sich mit essen ja stimmt
gammel steak wer auch mal wieder was das
ist ich hoffe wirklich einfach dass es
dafür gut schmeckt das sieht auf jeden
fall auch hier aus schon mal das ist
auch stabiler bild neben autos direkt ja
ich finde wirklich mir mal was dazu
kommt so ein fisherman's friends das
hier ist checken das ist eine richtige
suppe ist aber auch ja das ist schon
sehr gut verpacken findet soll wie im
vorjahr bei den gästen gerne lache ist
so vom aussehen her würde ich mir exakt
das bestellen es sieht sehr sexy aus auf
jeden fall warte also so sieht das aus
ich finde es sieht eigentlich genau
gleich aus oder bei mir sind halt so
garnelen drin und meint so joachim
verstarb sein
bei dir ist einfach schicken drin und
der reis die stabil aus fertig sein
wir machen wir beide den test ist okay
aber dafür dass das bild ist es ist sehr
scharf tja was halt ich bin auch voll
schärfe man verlegt worden davon
mindestens scharf gewürzt wird es jetzt
nicht klappt man kommt aus wien mit
schaf indischer finde ich schon mal
weshalb ich mir jetzt eigentlich
überlegt habe ursprünglich auch mit
strom wie das video aufzunehmen war war
ich mal neue sachen einfach ausprobieren
wollte nicht weil ich hätte auf jeden
fall kein schwimm- preis vom inter
bestellt und vielleicht wenn ich jetzt
mit skype ich probier's mal
naja meint richter gab bei manch eine
geile schärfe
ich mache mir wirklich scharfe sachen
gerne deswegen besuchen mich auch in
hamburg
es hat nicht mehr so die perfekte
temperatur aber ist es auch wirklich
nicht kalt oder befinden könnte werber
sollen auf jeden fall aber wieder auch
schon gesagt das ist jetzt nicht kalt ja
nicht mal mein bier und immerhin was
kannst du ja nehmen die das schicken wir
mal so ein bisschen schicken von luca
mit der pizzen werden so dreist kreis
haben wir den gleichen länger genau das
will ich mir bestellen ich bin ja diese
werden immer wenn ich beim essen
bestellen bestechlich reifen in davos
und gemüse
einfach nur lecker diese cocos soße
richtig geil richtig wild ich bin cool
einfach scheißegal schmecken englisches
bier trank ich hab dazu folgen
ich hoffe aber schon ein glas was sagst
du zum preis 31 eur 50 zwei gerichte und
getränke ist schon teuer für bestellt
ich meine dafür teile unserer vor augen
aber stellen wir kriegen die matura
aktuell ist es ja ins restaurant gehen
also ich bin positiv überrascht worden
eigentlich war ich war eigentlich so
überschreibt mannschaft in den laden
aufgehört land ina wilde dass sie für
ihren mann schickt das wären themen das
video lieferzeit ist ist ein flop für
mich ne wir waren jetzt zum glück nicht
ultra hungrig deshalb ging es klar aber
es ist lieferzeit ist nur zwei von zehn
jetzt läge aber dafür ist das format hat
richtig geil wenn man wirklich was
entdecken will und dann halt wirklich
was geiles entdeckt 100 prozent also ich
bin auch wie gesagt überrascht zwei von
zehn für liefern was gibst du dann hier
für eine note ich probiere jetzt auch
keinen unterschied zwischen cola light
und guckt normaler cola kraft überhaupt
kann man trinkt nicola spricht immer nur
wasser und auch wenn ich irgendwie fall
natürlich den koffeinhaltigen getränke
oder so auf die anderen die drinks oder
sorgt ja mein bier ich bin es wirklich
lecker allerdings muss ich sagen ich
habe mit sandra sonne bier
adventskalender aufgemacht und dann halt
eine menge schweiß bier dabei deswegen
schmeckt für mich wahrscheinlich jedes
bier gerade irgendwie gut wenn es nicht
irgendwie tanz ebhausen dreizehnten
jahrhundert von dem auf einer skala von
was machen wir ein bisschen komisch
den würde ich glaube ich in der acht
geben wenn so kölsch ist eine neuen und
sehen ist so des beraters und dem essen
würde ich wirklich in den neuen geben
neun von zehn für bestellten reist das
richtig lecker ja krass sieben von zehn
für mich interessant aber nicht meins
cola sechs konzernweit mag aber ich
meine es mein essen kriegt von mir eine
acht von zehn und da ist auch eine neun
von zehn das ist wirklichkeit ich würde
noch scharf gestellt aber das tut uns
gut also leute was neues ausprobiert wir
wurden belohnt sehr gut dass es heute
gelaufen ist wir sehen uns am sonntag
wieder wenden
neue folge einen tag persönlich verkauf
kommt wie immer und macht's gut
lucas wernig dem titel